[Music]
in the winter of 1995 scientists pointed
the Hubble telescope at an area of the
sky near the Big Dipper a spot that was
dark and out of the way of light
pollution from surrounding stars the
location was apparently empty and the
whole endeavor was risky what if
anything was going to show up over 10
consecutive days the telescope took
close to 150 hours of exposure of that
same area and what came back was nothing
short of spectacular an image of over
1,500 distinct galaxies glimmering in a
tiny sliver of the universe now let's
take a step back to understand the scale
of this image if you were to take a
ballpoint pen and hold it at arm's
length in front of the night sky
focusing on its very tip that is what
the Hubble telescope captured in its
first Deep Field image in other words
those 3,000 galaxies were seen in just a
tiny speck of the universe approximately
1/2 millionth of the night sky to put
all this in perspective the average
human measures about 1.7 meters with
Earth's diameter at 12,700 kilometers
that's merely 7.5 million humans lined
up head-to-toe
the Apollo 8 astronauts flew a distance
of 380,000 kilometers to the moon and
our relatively small Sun has a diameter
of about 1.4 million kilometers for 110
times the Earth's diameter a step
further the Milky Way holds somewhere
between 100 to 400 billion stars
including our Sun and each glowing dot
of a galaxy captured in the Deep Field
image contains billions of stars at the
very least almost a decade after taking
the Deep Field image scientists adjusted
the optics on the Hubble telescope and
took another long exposure over a period
of about four months this time they
observed 10,000 calories half of these
galaxies have since been analysed more
clearly in what's known as the extreme
deep field image or XDS by combining
over 10 years of photographs the xdf
shows galaxies so distant that they're
only one ten billions the brightness
that human eye can perceive so what can
we learn about the universe from the
Deep Field images in a studying the
universe
space and time are inextricably linked
that's because of the finite speed of
light so the field images are like time
machines for the ancient universe
they reach so far into space and time
that we can observe galaxies that
existed over 13 billion years ago this
means we're looking at the universe as
it was less than a billion years after
the Big Bang and have allowed scientists
to research galaxies in their infancy
the Deep Field images have also shown
that the universe is homogeneous that is
images taken at different spots in the
sky look similar
that's incredible when we think about
how fast the universe is why would be
expected to be the same across such huy
diseases on the scale of a galaxy let
alone the universe we are smaller that
we can readily comprehend but we do have
the capacity to wonder the question to
explore to investigate and to imagine so
the next time you stand gazing up in the
night sky take a moment to think about
the enormity of what is beyond for me
out in the dark spaces between stars
you